Do You Love Ranch everybody
um hidden Valley's new ice cream could
be your new sweet treat they made a
ranch flavored ice cream
yuck
what
like ice cream should be fruity flavors
you know chocolate stuff like that not
disgusting like ranch ranch goes on
salad and onion rings they're gonna come
up with blue cheese like how about a
thousand island ice cream it's like come
on man branch
Ranch ice cream who is eating that like
how fat do you have to be well you've
just given up and you're like give me
the ranch ice cream are you just like
having a hamburger and then putting a
ranch ice cream on top to hamburger and
then that's how you're gonna eat that I
just don't know what goes with ranch ice
cream I just or do you put lettuce on it
like what carrots Ranch ice cream nobody
wants this who wants this